[Music]
I'm part of the curvier population
Gabourey Sidibe opens up about her
weight-loss struggles for the first time
in her new memoir this is just my face
try not to stare I'm super super proud
of myself the Empire star reveals she
once battled with depression anxiety and
bulimia after being diagnosed with type
2 diabetes and undergoing weight-loss
surgery last year the 33 year old
actress explains why she decided to go
under the knife telling people magazine
quote I just didn't want to worry I
genuinely would worry all the time about
losing my toes I'm just living my life
Gabby adds she didn't get the surgery to
be beautiful quote I did it so I can
walk around comfortably in heels despite
a history of body shaming the actress
told ET back in December 2015
she's unbothered by online haters
I feel like haters are like ghosts or
aliens like you either believe in them
or you don't I believe in ghosts but I
don't believe in haters like I'm out
here winning so what is what's a hater